how are you
i'm doing well how are you doing good
good nice to see you
nice to see you um so i am curious uh
emily in paris big hit gets renewed for
season two
you got to work with david fincher on
this spectacular movie
um have you thought about playing the
lottery
um i i feel like i might have
won the lottery being able to work with
him
and then um and then getting engaged so
you know i feel pretty i feel pretty
lucky right now yeah i i don't i
was gonna uh i don't follow a lot of
people's personal lives so
congratulations
thank you um that's actually awesome
also by the way i like really respect
that i was freely giving you that
because i
felt like i answered the question but i
really respect the fact that you don't
yeah no i i uh yeah we can move on past
this it's uh oh yeah
this is the thing with collider we try
not to involve ourselves in you know
personal lives
about the work um uh i am curious
obviously
david fincher is a genius i mean i love
everything he does
uh i i'm very curious for you as someone
who's worked with a lot of different
filmmakers and on a lot of different
projects
did anything surprise you when you were
working with him on set
that maybe you weren't expecting he's
super funny
he's really funny and very vibrant
and the way in which he gives
direction and information to actors
as well as every head of department is
very very informative but at the same
time
very witty and very funny and we laughed
a lot on set and i don't think i was
expecting that
uh your first i'm gonna go backwards
it's your first day of filming
you're walking up to to get ready to
start on a scale of like one to ten
how nervous are you i think i was just
so excited
to be a small part in such a
great ensemble that i didn't feel this
incredible weight
um i felt like we'd done so much prep
work and they had already started
filming because i was in paris shooting
emily in paris and i
was flying back and forth for prep and
then they started filming so when i came
into it
everyone was already kind of getting
their like wheels in motion
but i remember my first scene actually
was me getting out of
the car and walking in which is the
first time you see me
and i remember just being like just
don't trip please just don't trip don't
trip
you're carrying something heavy and then
i was like i tripped i was like okay
well i got it out of the way it's great
we can now move on and
um but it was all in good fun and i i
think i was just so
excited i just still couldn't believe
that i was there to be honest i
was so honored to have been cast that i
was like i'm just gonna go with it
yeah i made a joke with tom i wanted to
know with him how much he paid to be in
the movie
it essentially feels like that i was
like i would sign up to just be
a glimpse in the background let alone
speak so
i i was i was down to be in any way that
i could
completely um i would imagine so you
read the script
you meet with them you have an idea of
what the film is going to be
what was your reaction actually seeing
the finished film and how did it compare
to what you envisioned going in
ice even though i knew it would be in
black and white it's still
shocking to see something in black and
white having filmed it in color
obviously
so meaning not filming it in color but
filming it looking at colors and
forgetting that they're going to be
gradients of gray
um i wasn't there for all of the filming
you know obviously my character is very
much
in one specific place and time so to see
the opulence of hearst castle and to see
all of the studio work
um was beautiful in comparison to
the beauty of victorville in that ranch
but it's like so
different and to see all the characters
together i mean i was just
i was so blown away and then you add on
the score
and it's it takes on a world of its own
and um
it was just a masterpiece when you watch
it and you're just like god i'm so happy
that i
get to be a part of this you know you
feel even more proud
totally i i think that listen i love the
movie so much
and i do think that cinephiles are
really going to respond to this
in a completely different way than maybe
the average
person who just sees casual movies um
thank you so much i think there's also
this deep set nostalgia
within this period and the way that the
film looks that
i know i myself am craving now more than
ever because we're all in this kind of
state of
mourning the world that was you know and
and now to be able to see something
where that
you really feel immersed in something of
the past is is a sense of escapism that
i've been craving
completely already got a wrap i'm just
going to say congrats again on the movie
congrats thanks it's so nice to see you
nice to see you good luck with the rest
of the speed dating i appreciate that
and stay safe later